good morning believe nation today's
message is dedicate time to your
business over to you Daymond John TV go
dedicate a certain amount of time to the
business two hours a week four hours a
week 50 hours a week no matter what it
starts to compound after the year one
after year to after your three if you
dedicated two hours a week to you know
this new hobby or love or you know
business you know at the end of the year
it's over a hundred hours put in don't
be in a rush first we'll learn all the
mistakes early and then have some kind
of strategy know that this is where you
want to be after year one two three four
and five and you have to really be
honest with yourself is the business
worth it is it costing too much because
you'll know I think a lot of businesses
fail because they give up too soon and
they stop letting the momentum work for
them I think it's super important to
dedicate time every day to your business
even if it's just half an hour half an
hour every single day no excuses to your
business to help it grow to allow for
that momentum to start to take hold it
can be really hard to work for an hour
on a day and then try to come back four
days later and work another hour like
you've lost a lot of little mention that
was built up and I get that you can't
come in at the start of a business work
full time and I'm not the guy who says
go quit your job spend all your life
savings cashing your retirement you know
sell your house and go start this
business I'm not that risky I'm not that
guy I like setting it on the side I like
proving to yourself there's more
spending more of your time on this
project but to make it work you have to
dedicate the time every single day to
make it happen and it's super hard
because life gets in the way because if
you have a job and you have you know a
family and maybe you get sick whatever
there's always something there's always
something right there's never a perfect
time there's always something that's
going to come up in the way that will
prevent you from doing the work on your
business it's always easy to go and do
more work because your boss that you
need to finish up on that project
nobody is forcing you to do this so you
have to dedicate that time in your
calendar you have to beat your own boss
you need to give yourself guidelines and
have standards for yourself and say if i
set a commitment to myself i'm going to
follow through on it because when you
commit to somebody else you'll do it
your boss tells you to do it you're
going to do but to yourself you let
things slide and you don't follow
through how many miss commitments have
you made for yourself and then didn't
follow through on it's too easy and so
that's why a lot of business never gets
never really get off the ground because
it's starting to stop and is starting to
stop and it's starting to stop where you
need to dedicate at least half an hour
every single day block it off in your
calendar don't let anything interrupt it
unless it's a massive emergency that's
your time it's just as important as if
you were meeting a boss at your work you
wouldn't just blow off that meeting that
something super important came up treat
your own time treat your own business
that importantly if you do that then
you'll actually out for momentum to
build up and grow so the question today
today is I'm curious for those of you
who are doing part-time work on your
business right now how do you schedule
your time in and also for everybody how
many hours do you work a week on your
business here's to find out leaving the
comments below I will join a discussion
thank you guys so much for watching have
an amazing day continue to believe and
I'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot events
you